لكن دعني أسألك لماذا
يقوم جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي بعملية عسكرية بينما
ينام المدنيون في أسرتهم؟ لا
يهاجم جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي وإسرائيل المدنيين عمدًا أبدًا، فنحن نستهدف
الإرهابيين الذين يطلقون
الصواريخ علينا، كما أوضحت بشكل صحيح أن
الجهاد الإسلامي أطلق النار  مائة صاروخ على
المدن الإسرائيلية ونعم، نرد ونرد
ونطلق النار على
الإرهابيين لسوء الحظ في غزة،
حماس الإسلامية لديها طريقة في
العمل حيث يحبون وضع
قاذفات الصواريخ حول
العائلات المدنية، وهذا أمر ساخر
وزن العملية،
أنا الوزير بينيت، لست متأكدًا مما إذا كنت قد
سمعت المقطع الصغير الذي قمنا بتشغيله من قبل
لأنك ربما كنت تقوم بالتجهيز،
كانت إحدى السيدات تقول بشكل أساسي إننا ننام
أثناء النهار ونستيقظ في الليل
من الواضح أننا خائفون  من بين هذه المعدلات في
الغارات الليلية، رأينا خمس نساء وأربعة
أطفال يقتلون صندوق النقد الدولي مما
أتذكر أنه وصفه بشكل صحيح بالضمانات
ولكن هذه كانت عملية مستهدفة، هذه
هي كلماتهم الآن. لقد سمعت
الحجة التي كثيرًا ما قدمتها تلك الميليشيات وأنت
تلمح إلى ذلك  هناك يستخدمون المدنيين كدروع بشرية
لكن أليس على إسرائيل
التزام بالالتفاف حول تلك الدروع
هنا على
إسرائيل التزام بالدفاع عن
شعبها ماذا ستفعل هو أه لو أه
أطفالك هل ستسمح لهم بالتواجد
بجوار قاذفات الصواريخ
لا أنا  لن أفعل ذلك ولكنني لن أستهدف
المدنيين سيدي وهذا هو سؤالي
لا أحد يستهدف المدنيين عيسى لا أحد
يستهدف المدنيين فهل
تتهم هل تتهم هؤلاء الأطفال
بأنهم جزء من هذا
لا أنا أتهم الجهاد الإسلامي
بقتل أطفاله  من خلال
إطلاق الصواريخ بشكل ساخر على الأطفال الإسرائيليين ولكنهم
يحيطون أسلحتهم بالمدنيين
في غزة، لا توجد طريقة
أكثر جبنًا مما
يفعلونه وعار عليهم، وأنا أقترح
أن يتوقفوا فورًا عن قتل
أطفالهم في هذه الحالة الساخرة.  الطريقة صحيحة
ولكن المداهمات الليلية عندما
يكون الأطفال والنساء نائمين، لا
أعتقد أن هناك طريقة لإنهاء دائرة العنف هذه،
هل لديك أي اقتراح آخر حول كيفية
إنهاء دائرة العنف، إذن
أنت  سياسي في لندن إذا لم يكن هناك
بالضبط وأعتقد أنه أه أيضًا
مناسب جدًا لتعلم الجلوس في أه في
غرف حول العالم وانتقاد
إسرائيل التي تقاتل للدفاع عن
شعبنا وأنا لا أخجل من ذلك
ولا أعتذر عن ذلك  أنا فخور
بالدفاع عن شعبنا، لقد فعلت ذلك عندما كنت في
الجيش، ولسوء الحظ نحن في
منطقة توجد فيها حماس الإسلامية هذه
المرة ليست حماس ولكن لدينا
الجهاد الإسلامي الذي يستيقظ ويبدأ في
إطلاق النار على الإسرائيليين.  هل سنفعل
ذلك نعم نحن ندافع عن أنفسنا ونعم
نحاول القضاء على المسلحين ونذهب إلى أبعد
الحدود لحماية حياة أه
غير المتورطين ولكن نعم لسوء الحظ بسبب
الطريقة التي يعملون بها إذا أردنا
إيقاف هؤلاء أه الإرهابيين علينا أن
أطلق النار عليهم وهم يختبئون بطريقة جبانة،
دعنا نتحدث مع السيد بينيت عن الوساطة.
لا أعرف إذا كنت قد سمعت
مراسلنا هيداسكال يقول هناك إننا
نسمع أن المصريين
يتوسطون هنا وأنهم ينخرطون في
ما يسمونه سيدي مكثف
التواصل لإلحاق الضرر بغزة هل
هناك مجال هل هناك شهية هنا لوقف
إطلاق النار
نعم هناك أه لم نسعى لهذه
الجولة أه لا نسعى لأي جولات في هذا الشأن
في الحقيقة أود أن أذكر
المشاهدين أن  في 2005 قمنا بإجلاء
قطاع غزة بالكامل من أه مواطنين
عسكريين سلمنا مفاتيح
السلطة لفتح وللأسف
تحولت إلى بيئة إرهاب معادية أه وكيان
منذ ذلك الحين
يجعل حياتنا بائسة لقد
ليس لدينا أي مطالبات إقليمية في غزة،
ليست لدينا احتياجات في غزة، كل ما نريده هو
السلام الهادئ والهدوء لشعبنا،
اليوم الذي يقررون فيه وقف إطلاق الحجارة
على إسرائيل سيكون اليوم الذي
سيكون هناك هدوء فيه، سيكون هناك
هذا التغيير يا سيدي إذا كانت
حماس  متورط لأن الجيش الإسرائيلي يقول
إنكم تعلمون أنه لا يرى مقدار
إطلاق الصواريخ لكن حماس تقول
خلاف ذلك إسرائيل قالت في الوقت نفسه إنها ليست
مهتمة بالحرب من ناحية أخرى
يقول رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو نتنياهو إن
إسرائيل مستعدة لتوجيه ضربات قاسية
وكان يقول فقط  في
الدقائق القليلة الماضية، قال مراسلنا للتو
إن هداس غولد تحدث في
الدقائق القليلة الأخيرة من البلاد وقال إن
الحملة لم تنته بعد، أي أن
الحملة لم تنته لأنه بينما
نتحدث الآن هناك
صفارات الإنذار  في جنوب إسرائيل بسبب
الصواريخ التي يتم إطلاقها علينا في هذه المرحلة،
نحن لا نسعى إلى أي عملية أخرى أه
ولكن في نفس الوقت وعلى نفس
المنوال أود أن أقول أنه إذا استمرت حركة الجهاد الإسلامي في
إطلاق النار أو إذا تورطت حماس
فسوف أعود
دعنا نتحول يا سيدي الآن بعد أن وضعتك
هنا في السياسة، إذا جاز لي، أتساءل إلى
أي حد يقدم هذا لرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو نوعًا من
الإرجاء السياسي. سألت هذا لأنني
رأيت اليوم أن القوة اليهودية هي
حزب يميني متطرف في
وقالت حكومة نتنياهو الائتلافية إنها ستنهي مقاطعتها
للحكومة رداً على هذه
الغارات الجوية.
لا أعلم أن إسرائيل لا تذهب إلى
العمليات لأسباب سياسية بينما
قد أكون منتقداً للحكومة
لسبب أو لآخر، يمكنني أن أؤكد لكم
ذلك  جميع الإسرائيليين من اليمين واليسار يدعمون
الجيش الإسرائيلي
والحكومة الإسرائيلية في العمليات التي تهدف إلى
الدفاع عن أطفالنا. أستطيع أن أخبركم
أنه في طريقي إلى هنا، علقت
وسط صفارات الإنذار في وسط إسرائيل، وهذا
جنون بكل بساطة، ونحن  علينا أن ندافع عن
أنفسنا، سندافع عن أنفسنا
ولن نعتذر عن ذلك